سفر قد يصبح اسهل واكثر سرعه في السنوات
المقبله ليس بعيدا ان تكون رحله من الرياض
او دبي الى واشنطن باقل من ساعتين ما ادري
بدل 16 ساعه تكون اربع ساعات يا ريت بحثوا
وعلماء مشاهدينا في عالم الطيران
ببريطانيا يوشكون على تطوير تكنولوجيا من
شانها ان تجعل الرحلات الجويه التجاريه
اسرع بعشرين مره
العلماء البريطانيون ايش فيهم بداوا طبعا
مشاهدينا في التجارب
العملي رحلات الفضاء في محاوله لاسقاطها
على الرحلات التجاريه طبعا لتسريع السفر
وهذه الدراسه البريطانيه الحاليه يمكن ان
تقلص الرحلات الجويه لاكثر من 20 ضعف
خلال السنوات العشره المقبله سيتم هذا
التقليص عبر خطه طموحه لنقل الركاب بين
الدول عابر الفضاء حقائق علميه مبهره
راويه عن عالم الطيران والسفر مع من
لميس هات الحقائق يا لميس مش مهم الوقت
المهم نوصل سلمى
الكثير من المسافرين يعتقدون ان هبوط
الطائره هو المرحله الاصعب في الرحله لكن
خبراء الطيران يؤكدون ان مرحله اقلاع
الطائره هي الاكثر خطوره بسبب احتمال
الاعطال والمشكلات المفاجئه ومن الحقائق
المهمه التي يجهلها المسافرين ان الاجواء
الماطره والرعديه تمر بالطائره بشكل مستمر
لكن الهندسه الدقيقه التي انشات عليها هذه
الطائرات تجعلها امنه ولا تسبب تلفها كذلك
فان طماطم طائرات الرحلات الطويله التي
تصل الى 18 ساعه في اليوم يمكن ان يرتاحوا
لعده ساعات خصوصا في الطائرات المجهزه
باماكن النوم لهم مثلا طائره بوينج 77
مجهزه بنحو 11 سريرا للطاقم وربما لا يعرف
الكثير من الناس ان الثقب الموجود في نافذ
الطائره له دور مهم جدا في الحفاظ على
الضغط الهوائي فيها حيث تساهم في تنظيمه
بشكل كبير وبالنسبه لاقنعه الاكسجين
الخاصه بالسلامه في الطائره التي يتم
الشرح عنها بدايه كل رحله فانها تحتوي على
15 دقيقه فقط من الاكسجين لكن ليس هناك
داعي للرعب فهي كافيه في حال الازمات التي
يمكن ان تحدث على كل حال سالنا الناس
الاردن ما الذي يثير فضولك او خوفك اثناء
رحلات الطيران نتابع الاجابات
[موسيقى]
واحد سبحان الله خلص بطلع وبسيبها لرب
العالمين تتوكل على الله بتطلع في الطياره
صراحه
اقلاعها بكون متوتر اعوضها عادي بس لما
يكون كمان مطبات هوائيه بتكون شوي مخيفه
الاقلاع والهبوط دائما له يعني
رونك مختلف سواء بروح المغامره او الخوف
او يعني الشعور الغريب تخوفات العاده
الناس الطبيعيين بحسوها هي مفهومه يعني
لها تفسير دائما هندسي ولذلك صدقا انا
بسافر يعني اكثر مره في السنه وما عندي
هالتخوفات ابدا لا والله طلعت بسياره
وطلعت
بالقطار وطلعت بالماخره اما طيران ان شاء
الله
الله يحفظكم جميعا
[موسيقى]
من بيروت الطياره الكابتن فادي رمضان اهلا
فيك كابتن معنا في صباح العربيه
صباح الخير
خلينا نحكي اكثر عن النقطه اللي كل الناس
بتخوفوا منها موضوع السلامه الكل بخاف
بانه لو وقعت الطياره لما يصير في مطبات
هوائيه طبعا الرعب ينتشر في طياره ولكن مع
انه كل العلماء وكل اللي بيعملوا ابحاث
والخبراء الطيران بقولوا انه الطياره اكثر
امانا بمراحل هائله عن السياره مثلا
مزبوط الطيران هو اامن وسيله نقل بالعالم
يمكن الباص باوروبا شويه صغيره بضاهيها بس
غير هيك هي امن وسيله نقل بالعالم خاصه
لما نقارن العدد الميل اللي بتقطعه
الطائره او الكيلومترات بالنسبه للسيارات
بتشوف الارقام مختلفه بشكل هائل بالنهايه
السياره انت حواليك كله سيارات اخرى وكلن
عم يتسارعوا بشكل هائل وما في حدا عم ينظم
القصه الا كم ضوء هون وكم دوار
الحوادث بيصيروا اكثر والناس ما انهم
مدربه رخص الناس تبع السيارات مع هالدرجه
المدربين عليها مش نحن سنه ونصتنا تدريب
وضغطون 6 شهور بس من على الرواق مش مثل
الطيران طيب فادي اليوم العلماء راح يخلوا
هذه الرحله اللي من الرياض الى واشنطن
تقريبا اقل من ساعتين اليوم رحله مثلا من
دبي الى
الى اوكلاند في نيوزيلندا 18 ساعه تقريبا
الاسئله التي ترد في ذهني اي الاماكن افضل
اخف تعبا ولماذا اختار هل الامان والسلامه
في درجه رجال الاعمال ام في الدرجه
السياحيه وغيرها
كله مثل بعضه بالحقيقه في فروقات صغيره
اذا كان المقعد لقدام او لوراء هيدي في
احب في بحاسس عليها اكتشفوا انه اذا كان
المقعد موجه للخلف في عندك امان اكتر بس
عم نحكي عن فواصل صغيره واذا بتحط المقعد
للخلف الناس حيحسوا بالدوار اكتر
[موسيقى]
من هيك خلوا بالكراسي مثل ما هن لانه عم
نحكي عن فواز صغيره بالنهايه الطائره اذا
كان يمكن مقعده شوي صغيره لورا بتفرق معه
بصفر فاصله 001 اذا كان مقعده قريب من
بزنس لاس بصير 0.00 ما بتختلف كتير
بالنهايه الطائره هي كلها على بعضها امنه
نحن هدفنا مش انه بحال تحطم شو صار
الهدفنا نحن نتفادى التحطم من اساسه
بنتفادى الحادث من اساسه هناك عالم
الطيران بيدرس الحادث كانه يعني مش كانه
بيدرس الحادث بكل بكل شيء عنده ليقدر
يكتشف كيف يتفاديه بالمستقبل هذا الهدف
تبعنا ما هدفنا انه نعمل حادث ونحن حالنا
هدفنا ما نعمل تكنولوج
يا اللي عمالهم بطوروها لحتى يخلوا عمليه
الطيران اسرع بكثير هل ممكن انه تؤثر على
الامان ممكن تخفض الامان في الطياره بما
انها الطياره عم بتسافر بسرعه هائله
هلا ما لازم ننسى انه ايام زمان كان عنا
طائره سريعه كتير سوبر سونيك هي اسمها
الكونكورد المشكله توقفت مش الامان مشكله
الكونكورد توقفت هو من وراء غلاء سعر
الوقود وقديه سعر غاليه سعر التيكت بس
الكونكورد كانت بتطير باربع ساعات تعمل
لندن لنيويورك
اسرع من سرعه الصوت
يعني عم نحكي عن طائرات مثل طائرات
الحربيه
الجديده عم بيعملوها ببريطانيا هاي
التكنولوجيا حتقرب بالطيار اكثر بالفضا
وحسن ما فهمتها انا يعني وبصير تتسارع مع
لما يكون الضغط الجوي فوق اوطى بكثير
بتكون بصراحه هيك تكنولوجيا حتطول نتيجه
يعني
قياس موجوده هلا بس حتاخد وقت قبل ما تطلع
لانه بالعالم الطيران بعندك سلام وامان
وعندك امتحانات وتجارب وقفه
فادي سريعا سريع رحله من من دبي الى
نيوزيلندا تكفير ذنوب هذه 18 ساعه ليش ما
يسمح لنا ندخل مثلا على الطياره ليش ما
يسمح لنا انه بالاقلاع نشغل التلفونات او
تسكير الشباك له خاصه بضبط عيون النظر
تضلك تقدر تطلع لبرا بس اثناء الاقلاع
والهبوط مش اثناء الرحله اثناء الرحله
بتسكر كل الشبابيك قد ما بدك ما عندك
مشكله بس اثناء الاقلاع والهبوط ما لازم
تسكرهم عشان تكون قادره تشوف برا بخصوص
تليفونات باسوا على اجهزه الملاحه مش حدا
التليفونات كل الاجهزه الكترونيه بيطلعوا
على كل حال
في احتمال صغيره ياثره بلاها والدخان
بالنهايه لممنوع تدخن جوات المطعم
طيب حطوا لنا
المدخنين غرفه التدخين
شكرا
بس للمدخنين المط
بات مش طبيعي اذا كان في
غيوم او او مضبوط بس تغيير هواء وحراره ها
هي ولا مره بحياتها صارت طياره صار لها
شيء مرض مطبات هوائيه فادي بس اهم شيء
لما يتكلم لانه ما نفهم شيء وهو اللي
يتكلم
صحيح في سؤال سريع ايها اخطر الاقلاع ولا
الهبوط
الهبوط انا بتهيا بصراحه مثل بعض الفرق
بيناتهم هو بس وحده عندك محركات على قوه
ووحده المحركات حتكون على قوه خفيفه وكل
وحده عندها متطلباتها
حساسين مش خطرين
[موسيقى]
خيار
شكرا يا فادي ان شاء الله توصل بالسلامه
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات